how about
figuring out how to motivate
the students hi there steve kaufman here
today to talk again about language
learning and to talk about how languages
should be taught in school
with particular reference to an article
that appeared in the guardian from the
uk a leading newspaper in the uk
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and
if you're following me on your podcast
please leave a review
so this um article because i follow
things in the news uh related to
language learning so here was this
article in the guardian about
a recommendation from a body in the uk
that concerns itself with education
that suggesting that a new
approach to language learning one that
would sort of inject some more
enthusiasm
into language learning would be to
have a list of 1700 basic words that
students would be
required to learn
and this of course brought a tremendous
sort of wave of criticism from people
who are involved with language teaching
saying
you can't just uh learn from lists
that's going to discourage people that's
not going to
create a sort of a sense of love of
learning a language so i sort of thought
about this and i did a lot of reading on
the subject
so first of all there is a bit of a
crisis surrounding language learning in
the uk
even though they are just across the
channel from france uh not far away from
spain
uh not to mention
other countries of europe
uh not to mention the fact that
we can easily connect with with china
with with the middle east and learn all
these different languages and yet
interest in language learning is
declining and i did some research
and uh
i think more than 50 percent of schools
give 45
minutes a week
of instructional time to language
learning so very little time is spent
with language learning interest in
languages is declining
one of the reasons given is that
students think that
languages are difficult so it's a risky
subject to take up because you may not
do well
and so that might affect your chances of
getting into university and so forth and
so on
so i thought about this so on the one
hand
of course it's hard to learn from a list
but on the other hand i thought you know
if you have a very concrete specific
goal
you have to learn 1700 words
then it's very clear what you have to do
in order to
get grades on
language whichever german spanish french
um
and i think there's something to be said
for that because i think
now a lot of people don't know why
they're even bothering to learn the
language they don't know what they're
supposed to achieve
unfortunately
this recommendation also suggests that
the students
be required to use these words and to
use them correctly that's much much more
difficult
i think the objective of any language
program
should be
to make the students
like learning the language
even if they're not tremendously
motivated
to eventually use the language
if they like the process because it's
very clear-cut i have to learn 1700
words i'm going to go about learning
them
that i think it's possible might induce
more people to get interested in in
language learning because the task is
kind of finite yeah i can do that if i
go at it for five years i can learn 1700
words
so on that level it's not a bad idea
it's not a good idea in my opinion to
demand grammatical
uh accuracy from language learners in
school because so few of them end up
speaking the language what does it
matter whether they are able to nail
niceties of grammar
at the age of 12. to me it doesn't
matter
if there's some way of making them enjoy
the process of language learning so that
they expose themselves to the language
they
develop some degree of comprehension
they develop a certain level of
vocabulary that's good enough
and some of those people will be
motivated enough to take it to another
level right now
very few relatively few
graduates of schools in the uk
end up speaking another language the
lowest level of any country in the
european union
they're not no longer in the european
union say in europe
and i don't think the situation is much
different in north america
so
but where i think they've gone they've
got it wrong with this list of 1700 key
words that you must learn
is just let them learn any 1700 words
why should you determine which words
they have to learn
and if
you set it up so that they learn these
words through a process of listening and
reading
like link
where you're looking at words and saving
words and we can keep track of the words
you've learned and we can even test you
on your comprehension of these words in
context using closed tests using
multiple choice and so forth flash cards
whatever it might be
but why say you have to learn these
words because one thing we know for sure
is that
the high frequency
words they're going to show up anyway so
the first even thousand words if you do
a lot of reading and listening you're
going to get those words because you're
going to meet them so often
apparently theoretically you need to
meet a word eight times in order to have
a 50 chance of remembering it so that's
gonna happen for the first thousand
words and then if you look at any
analysis of frequency frequency drops
off so fast that for the next thousand
words so that might get us closer to
where
this british
educational you know authority was
proposing 1700 words you end up having
to read
two or three times as much in order to
have a chance of meeting these words
often enough to remember them
besides which frequency drops off so
quickly that it doesn't really matter
whether you learn
the next thousand or the next the
thousand after that they're all a lot
less frequent and so what matters much
more
is
what subject matter are you covering if
you are interested in sports there are
certain words that will appear more
frequently if you're interested in
economics other words will appear more
frequently and as long as you have 2 000
words in other words if you have exposed
yourself to enough of the language
listening and reading that you actually
know 2 000 or 1700 words whichever words
they are
good enough now how can i get into the
difference between
word families and words however you want
to count them if it's 1700 word families
maybe it's 5 000 words it doesn't matter
some number some arbitrary number is
what a student is responsible to learn
not necessarily this specific list of
words but a specific number of words and
you go and read whatever you want to
read and listen to in that language
and we will test you on it we'll test
you on comprehension
and if you do okay then you're
considered to have passed in fact i
wouldn't even test them on comprehension
in terms of you know answering questions
about what happened in something they
read because that's a different skill
again that's the skill of trying to
remember what you heard
uh if we're just testing them on say the
the objective is to get you to where you
recognize
in context two thousand three thousand
words we test you on that you do that
that's what's going to give you your
mark in the language
that might give the learners a greater
sense of achievement
those people who are inclined those
learners who are inclined to get
enthusiastic
about the language through their
listening and reading through that sense
of achievement of understanding more and
more of a language of enjoying content
of interesting of interest to them
those people will take it further
and so with them
the objective of turning learners into
enthusiastic learners will be achieved
remember
there are two keys i often talk about
three but let's talk about two
fundamental keys to language learning
one is the attitude of the learner the
enthusiasm the interest the motivation
and the other is the time spent so if
teachers can motivate their learners to
spend the time
for whatever reason because have a very
concrete task learn 2 000 or 3 000 words
or because through learning these words
and phrases through a lot of listening
and reading
they have a sense of achievement and
they have this sense of understanding in
other language and then they are
interested in learning more about the
language then that again is a major uh
you know should be a major goal of of
language instruction i always have
whenever i talk about how i learn
languages inevitably the language
teachers who prefer to have and who
always say well that's fine for you
because you're motivated but i have a
classroom full of unmotivated learners
so therefore your system would never
work
therefore they do what they've always
done which in fact isn't very motivating
which is teaching grammar and then
testing them on grammar and finding that
they get six out of ten and so therefore
they're discouraged so that's not
motivating maybe rather than saying well
steve you're motivated so your system
works for you but i have unmotivated
students therefore it won't work how
about
figuring out how to motivate
the students
maybe not all of them but a larger
number than are motivated right now and
maybe with an approach like that we
won't see this dropping off of interest
in language learning which is a major
issue in the uk
uh and probably in in north america
despite all of the enthusiastic teachers
i've met them i've met them at the
american council of teachers of foreign
languages and there are lots of them
and yet the statistics are there there's
less and less interest in foreign
languages so something is not working
one solution suggested here by this and
i'm going to leave all the relative
links in the description box
is this idea of having a list of words
that you have to learn
it may or may not work
but obviously what is
and this is despite
years of research
studies whenever i go and search on the
internet i found detailed studies about
all different aspects of of language
most of which refer to what's happened
what happens in a classroom as if that's
the only place where you learn languages
which of course it isn't
the the classroom should be where you
turn people on to learning languages
they will learn them elsewhere on their
own if they're turned on but despite 50
years of research
all we see is declining interest in
language learning we don't see
increased you know success in language
instruction at school in the uk or north
america maybe it's not so complicated
maybe people shouldn't over complicate
it maybe they should just stick with
what krashen says and what i def
definitely have experienced in my
language learning and that is if you can
expose yourself to enough of the
language
you're going to learn
and some people will be motivated enough
to do that others won't be
and if they at least have a very
concrete task at school you have to
learn two thousand words we're going to
test you on it in using closed tests or
multiple joys so then they have a clear
idea of what they're expected to do
some people will only do that and i
think maybe as many people as now or
more will be motivated to take it
further and so with that i'll leave you
with i'd be interested in your comments
on this and maybe a couple of videos
where i've talked a bit about motivation
and input and how that helps us learn
languages thank you for listening bye
for now